it's official fans are loving the new
Star Wars show Ahsoka and they're taking
to social media and droves to share
their thoughts after seeing Dawson bring
the character into the live action realm
and the Mandalorian they're thrilled her
solo Adventure is off to such a strong
start one fan posted on Twitter the
first two episodes of Ahsoka just
deliver on every front everything that
made Rebels so special is beautifully
translated into live action and the
Heart and Soul of this incredible story
remains strong bologna has done it once
again General cindola
see you there's even something for Star
Wars fans who have serious franchise
fatigue according to this fan who posted
I actually like it a lot so far and I've
been super critical of Disney Canon for
the most part translating a beloved
animated show into live action could
have been a tough feat but clearly
feloni and his cast met this challenge
head on as one excited fan wrote the
first two episodes of Ahsoka were so
freaking good like in my opinion this is
already some of the best Star Wars
content poetic Cinema the Star Wars
Rebels solidarity man I cannot wait for
more episodes to come